il disagio
a disagio di essere qui di fronte a una
maggioranza di donne anzi praticamente
quasi solo donne
quindi sono a disagio in effetti sono un
uomo poi dopo i cosiddetti insomma anche
una sorta di inadeguatezza essendo un
uomo come faccio a parlare di donne
però è una di quelle cose che io è uno
di quegli elementi di nei quali membri
mi piace parlare e ne parlò a scuola ne
parlò nel nelle aule in cui insegno
eccetera perché ho delle figlie un paio
sono qui ho tre figlie ho una moglie ho
avuto una madre una suocera e quindi
sono circondato da donne quindi tutto
sommato qualcosa sulle donne
forse lo posso lo posso raccontare e e
poi sono voluto partire da lontano e
quindi ho intitolato il mio intervento
negli occhi di eva perché è ma è la
primogenita ice insomma del del genere
umano tutto visto ed è stata la prima
donna allora ne ho parlato a mia moglie
di cui a cui parlo sempre un po dei miei
progetti eccetera e naturalmente mi ha
detto no non ci siamo sei vecchio
partita erano tutte cose che sanno già
tutti che tutti hanno già visto non ci
sono assolutamente non c'è ragione di
parlare di queste cose allora per una
volta in una dialettica familiare tipica
le ho dato io ho dato ascolto e ho detto
va bene parliamo di cose un po più
recente e in effetti questo quando mi
hanno chiesto di venire qui a dire
qualcosa
credo fosse mese di luglio e quindi
eravamo nel pieno di questi fenomeni
calo racket e una donna
la conoscete capitano del sì watch che
ha fatto esattamente quello che secondo
me da tremila anni come minimo
le donne fanno quando vogliono prendere
la leadership vale a dire rompere le
regole tendono a rompere le regole del
resto ci sono delle regole e molto
spesso imposte da altri evidentemente
probabilmente da uomini ma comunque da
altri e loro le rompono e carola in
questo senso è stato un bell'esempio di
rompere le regole non poteva entrare nel
porto ha deciso di entrare nel porto e
ha rotto le regole anche quasi speronato
un'altra nave ma questa è la meno
importante è poi sempre in quel periodo
avevamo megan rapinoe ve la ricordate
megara pino è una giocatrice di calcio
il capitano della squadra di caccia
degli stati uniti d'america che poi ha
vinto anche i campionati mondiali che si
ritengono in francia la cosa
interessante di in questo caso di megan
anche lei il capitano quindi la cosa
interessante abbiamo due capitali ma
anche lei ha rotto le regole invitata
alla casa bianca preventivamente ha
detto subito no io non ci vengo perché
non mi piace chi sta alla casa bianca e
quindi niente
anche in questo caso un modo di rompere
le regole due capitani stamattina
qualcun altro ha parlato di autorità che
quindi hanno l'autorità di fare
determinate cose che decidono però di
rompere le regole in modo diverso e
quindi di affrontare il mondo con occhi
completamente diversi ma io sono
testardo e quindi alla fine sono tornato
alla mia ispirazione iniziale e va cosa
c'entra e va in tutto ciò questa è la
nascita di eva michelangelo è cappella
sistina
la nascita di eva
che è 14 interessante se guardate bene
vedete adamo che si fa sonnellino come
spesso accade
e mentre lui dorme qualcun altro decide
di togliergli una costola e di creare e
va e va quindi come un sicuro prodotto
dell'uomo sotto tutti i punti di vista
sicuramente un'idea di questo genere
voleva anche essere l'idea di
subordinazione necessaria nella donna
rispetto all'uomo il fatto che comunque
tutto dipende dall'uomo sicuramente c'è
questo ed è stato raccontato
probabilmente in molti in molte modalità
abbiamo anche se stamattina sentito
qualcosa su questo però la cosa
interessante è che eva però da subito
decide di cambiare le cose e nel
paradiso terrestre non ci sta poi così
bene o comunque anche li decide di
rompere le regole e va la prima donna è
la prima rompe le regole
qualcuno gli ha detto non devi mangiare
da quell'albero e lei invece
tranquillamente è la prima cosa che fa
si prende una mela e la offre ad adamo e
di conseguenza ecco che siamo nel pieno
di questa modalità il secondo me ma era
una leader era sicuramente una capace di
mostrare leadership
oggi la chiameremo un influence è capace
di influenzare adamo il follower
l'uomo e di condurlo fuori un po tristi
è nell'immagine di di masaccio tristi ma
però in un mondo completamente nuovo
dove hanno potuto muoversi
allora questa questa cosa della
ritroviamo poi la ritroviamo
costantemente lo facciamo una cavalcata
veloce perché non abbiamo molto tempo
antigone famosissima conosciuta
siamo nella classicità grecia greca
antigone famosa perché anche lei ha
rotto le regole ha deciso di rompere le
regole le regole le imponevano
del re di tebe creonte di non seppellire
il fratello e lei invece decide di
mettere assolutamente a repentaglio la
propria vita la propria libertà e decide
di seppellire dare una degna sepoltura a
polinice qui dietro ci sta anche il
concetto di valore valore della vita
umana se volete o valore di qualsiasi
altro elemento che antigone fa suo
rompendo le regole resistendo all
autorità in questo caso il mo visto che
lei non ne aveva di autorità e facendo
anche una brutta fine perché poi viene
incarcerato e poi e poi si suicida
prima di essere salvata allora il
capitano antigone l'hanno definita anche
carlo racket e qual è l'elemento di
connessione proprio questo elemento di
valori valori della dignità della vita
umana la sepoltura salvataggio possiamo
metterli insieme come vogliamo persone
quindi che rompono le regole per
rispondere a determinati valori esempi
di leadership femminile e poi la più
famosa di tutte forse giovanna d'arco
un'altra chiaro ottone regole un'altra
che è appreso l'autorità che ha preso la
leadership combattendo contro tutto si è
tagliato i capelli avrà tutto quel che
non bisognava farsi tagliare i capelli
si è vestita da uomo s'è vestita da
soldato ha combattuto ha condotto
eserciti e ha vinto e poi viene bruciata
sul rogo
un altro esempio di una leadership
femminile che rompe tutte le regole si
dà il potere di fare qualcosa e poi
finisce veramente male come come le
streghe allora siamo nel seicento
un altro esempio di leadership al
femminile le cose vanno un po meglio
artemisia gentileschi credo faccia parte
del della dimensione femminista allora
intanto decide di fare la pittrice
decide di fare la pittrice che non era
un mestiere da donna tipicamente si fa
chiamare pittura
ecco interessante anche questo non si fa
tanti scrupoli è una pittura si firma la
pittura ma per prima di evitare una
pittura deve imparare a dipingere allora
le danno un maestro e il maestro la
violetta
eppure eppure
riesci ad andare avanti riesce a fare
incarcerare il suo maestro stupratore lo
fa condannare anche se poi la condanna
piuttosto lieve e lei riesce a diventare
una pittrice anzi riesce a diventare la
pittura riesce a vivere del suo lavoro
gira per l'europa molto apprezzata molto
richiesta e vive assolutamente il suo
lavoro
virginia moso direbbe alla sua stanza e
riesce ad avere dei soldi grazie al suo
lavoro e poi arriviamo all'ultimo
esempio vi voglio fare gen io siamo
sempre in ambito storico qui siamo
proprio non è più un personaggio storico
è un personaggio letterario però frutto
di una sorella bronte charlotte bronte
c'erano pronte insieme alle sue sorelle
erano tre erano scrittrici per poter
scrivere nell'ottocento nel primo
ottocento hanno dovuto darsi dei nomi
maschili o che non si capiva bene siano
maschili o femminili potevano essere
entrambi l'unico modo per poter
pubblicare poter essere eletti e poter
anche ricevere ovviamente i diritti
d'autore
bello come come esempio anche qui di
leadership al femminile ma ancora più
bello è il personaggio di generi geni
che secondo me rappresenta benissimo la
dimensione della leadership al femminile
ma ormai non più nel modo del rompere le
regole ma in una dimensione
completamente nuova che è quella
dell'affermazione di sé la capacità di
affermare il proprio sé genere è un
esempio di questo un esempio letterario
siamo d'accordo però estremamente
interessante da quali ci si può ispirare
da questo io l'ho scoperto non perché
l'abbia conosciuto direttamente da solo
ma perché alcune donne giovani donne
quando gli chiedevo dimmi un libro di me
un film che ti rappresenta
mi dicevano genie
e aveva prodotto andarono alla leggere e
in effetti ha scoperto che è un esempio
fantastico di affermazione di sé un
esempio fantastico di leadership di una
persona di una donna che si costruisce
la propria vita che si indirizza la
propria vita che ha una propria visione
se volete indipendente che non si lascia
soggiogare da altri il concetto di
affermazione di sé ed è qui secondo me
il futuro della leadership al femminile
affermazione di sé è una formula io
insegno comunicazione nel mio ultimo
libro parlo delle formule che sono una
cosa che oggi va molto di moda che
funziona molto affermazioni disse
formula semplice e che dice già tutto
affermazione significa devo comunicare
in modo chiaro mettere un punto
affermare quello che voglio dire è poi
se quello che sono
quello che voglio essere la
consapevolezza della mia identità del
mio essere
l'affermazione di sé è quello che nella
mia esperienza spesso manca alle donne
che vogliono essere leader
quando faccio coaching spesso a delle
donne anche in azienda quindi manager se
volete cosa scopro scopro che sono molto
brave in ruoli solo ruoli di genitori e
quindi di madre sanno accudire sanno
dare indirizzo sanno proteggere e poi
dall'altro lato hanno quest altra
dimensione un po diversa che è quella
della figlia o del figlio se preferite
del bambino sono bravissime a ribellarsi
quando è necessario riescono a rompere
le regole le abbiamo visto dei tanti
esempi
quello che manca molto spesso non sempre
evidentemente è invece la capacità di
essere adulti
cosa significa essere adulti significa
essere donne significa essere capaci di
affermare il proprio sé civica essere
alla pari degli altri alla pari delle
altre donne alla pari
degli uomini ed è questo che mi ha molto
colpito ingegner è una giovane donna che
sa mettersi alla pari e non si subordina
a nessuno ieri sera poi avuto
un'illuminazione scusatevi mezzo al
vento di milano
a un certo punto è venuta un'altra
un'altra considerazione avendo subito
qui giner era orfana e non aveva figli
era costretta fin da quando era bambina
ed essere adulta a trattare alla pari
con gli altri non aveva passato queste
esperienze che sono formative che sono
fondamentali che dobbiamo fare non c'è
alcun dubbio ma ha avuto questa come
dire questo passaggio un po strano
allora io non sto dicendo che dobbiamo
rifiutare i genitori discutere il ruolo
di figli eccetera ma sicuramente c'è da
incrementare questa affermazione di sé
questa consapevolezza e questa capacità
di muoversi alla pari scusate io sono un
professore per chi non avesse capito e
quindi sono quello che vi deve mostrare
una bella matrice io voglio non ottengo
perdente pensate ad antigone antigone
una perdente è riuscito a ottenere
qualcosa ma alla fine muore un altro
un'altra possibilità è quella della
vittima ne abbiamo parlato prima ne ha
parlato prima
le vittime ci sono le vittime non c'è
del mondo il nostro mondo
sfortunatamente ci sono molte vittime
però anche questa è una cosa che
dobbiamo evitare
io voglio qualcosa e non riesco e la non
voglio qualcosa e lo ottengo quanto di
peggio ci possa essere un'altra figura
un'altra dimensione che dobbiamo evitare
e invece con gli esempi che vi ho fatto
ecco che il concetto di resistenza
diventa molto importante nel momento in
cui rompiamo le regole stiamo facendo
una resistenza a qualcuno che vuole
imporci qualcosa e noi non la vogliamo
io non voglio in un ottengo resisto
benissimo fantastico è un aspetto già
positivo mentre il 20
la vittima il perdente sono due aspetti
negativi qui siamo già nella positività
al massimo che dobbiamo ottenere che
dobbiamo cercare è il potere io voglio
io ottengo il potere personale ecco
questa è la leadership al femminile
secondo me quella di ricercare questo
potere personale grazie a questa
capacità di mettersi alla pari di
comunicare di comunicare che cosi
comunicare i propri valori di far
sentire i propri valori e abbiamo un
altro esempio sotto questo punto di
vista veramente recente greta greta nel
suo piccolo di una ragazza è riuscita a
mettere in evidenza proprio questa
dimensione il potere personale personal
soft power lo chiamo spesso potere
personale il potere che è sempre
personale il potere non me lo dà nessuno
l'autorità vela da qualcuno
l'autorevolezza me la danno gli altri il
potere melo date voi non c'è nessun
altro che lo può dare soltanto noi ce lo
possiamo dare lei se l'è dato se l'hai
dato ed è riuscita a imporre i propri
valori
pensate a chi capacità di leadership e
ha mosso tutto il mondo e continua a
muovere tutto il mondo cosa che tutti i
grandi consensi di politici di
amministratori eccetera non sono mai
riusciti a fare lei c'e riuscita è
riuscita a fare questa dimensione a
lavorare su questa dimensione ottenere
questo risultato
un esempio di leadership al femminile
secondo me estremamente interessante
tanto che è diventata è andata sulla
copertina è quindi ormai il successo è
sicuro la copertina di time che che dice
il potere della gioventù no non è il
potere della gioventù è il potere di una
donna che ha saputo muoversi in modo
indipendente per far valere i propri
valori
fantastico io spero che possa continuare
che non si che continui nel miglior modo
possibile
e allora ecco che torniamo alla nostra
alla nostra e va perché perché e va
tutto sommato è stata abilissima e
secondo me dovrebbe rimanere un modello
perché negli occhi di eva vedo questa
capacità di muoversi alla pari con adamo
se mostra pari non si è mosso in modo
subordinato dopo forse è venuta
subordinazione ma quando erano lì erano
esattamente da fare anzi è riuscita a
guidarlo fuori dal paradiso che forse è
stato anche una buona cosa tutto sommato
con tutte le cose negative che possiamo
trovarci ed è nei suoi occhi che io vedo
la possibilita di per le donne di
trovare questo potere personale nei suoi
occhi negli occhi di eva che vedo la
possibilità di espressione di questa
affermazione di sé ed è negli occhi di
eva che io vedo la possibilità di
mantenere il vostro potere questo potere
che deve esserci che un potere personale
che deve essere assolutamente non
disperso grazie
[Applauso]